in america yesterday drastic measures
were taken as two of the nation's
biggest states joined a third
in ordering all non-essential workers to
stay
home now new york and california
illinois are in lockdown mode
the latest numbers show why at least 260
people in the u.s
are known to have died following
infection more than 5 300 new cases were
reported friday bringing the current
total
to more than 19 thousand michael george
is in times square with more michael
good morning
good morning dana jeff the new york
order goes into effect
sunday at 8 p.m so the state's 19
million residents
are being told to stay at home as much
as possible and
all social gatherings of any size and
for any reason
are now banned with new york joining
california and illinois
70 million americans are now being told
to stay at home
we're affected by the governor's orders
as increased testing
showed an increase in cases governor
andrew cuomo reported new york
experienced a dramatic spike by friday
morning
after another 10 thousand people were
tested new york now has
7 000 cases that compares to
state of washington that has 1 000
california that has 1 000 and change
so you can see that new york is in a
dramatically different position
the stay at home statewide order went
into effect on friday in california
leaving eerily empty streets and tourist
attractions without visitors
officials feared the worst if nothing
was done
half the state's 40 million residents
could get the virus
as i say there's a social contract here
people i think recognize need to do more
and to meet this moment
under governor newsome's order it's a
misdemeanor to go out in california
except to essential businesses
pharmacies gas stations and grocery
stores
are open jeff porter stocked up in los
angeles after listening to the governor
i feel like he wouldn't have done it
unless they really felt it was necessary
so i don't mind that he did that with
400 cases in illinois governor jb
pritzker appealed to residents not to
panic
there is no need to run out and hoard
food gas or medicine buy what you need
within reason there is enough to go
around
while businesses are expecting relief it
may be too little too late for many
workers
sheila redd lost her job as a school bus
driver because her school
closed how we were going to get paid it
was like
what was we going to do from that point
forward some economists estimate
two to three million people lost jobs
just this week
you sit at home you watch the news and
it feels so far away
until it reaches so close to home the
rising death toll is painfully personal
for stacy silva
her 66 year old father died this week
he was lovable he was kind
this week the u.s death toll from the
coronavirus more than tripled
i wanted to reach out and tell his story
because this is not a joke people
so what does a stay-at-home order mean
well here in new york it means people
are only expected to go out for
groceries
medical care and exercising alone now
businesses like hospitals and groceries
are still open but some
other businesses have been deemed
essential as well including mass transit
utilities
and us in the news media as well dana
jeff
all right michael thank you we did show
the number of cases by the way it is
worth noting 147 people have
also recovered